o lado pessoal daqui quem não fala em
dar que sejam muito bem vindos em mais
um vídeo e o estrago de hori é um jogo
que vai pessoal este é um remake do pt
salão multiuso que o demo que tinha
feito pra pés 4 niquinho porque o jogo
entretanto foi apagada e tal eo jogo foi
cancelado e eu não sei o que aconteceu
ao jogo e vai largar só vamos morar aqui
preparamos a pipoca vai colocar manteiga
e vai desembarcar ok agora quero mostrar
lá precisa de concentração porque tu
estás dentro de uma casa que nós temos
aqui temos aqui o paizinho da família e
muitos contratos de ilusões que barulho
é extra
vocês já ouviram isto aqui o que é que
luta uma coisa ali qualquer coisa o
cheiro é isso aí é sombra do caminheiro
ok ok qualquer coisa
exatamente isso hoje marca 1159 o que
quer dizer que falta um minuto para a
meia noite e amanhã à noite que vão
acontecer as coisas macabras mil/dia o
gesto é sombra tem uma textura brutal eu
acho que tem que ir mesmo em frente né ô
ô ô é normal esse barulho e welton fazer
isso ok sou eu sou eu vamos embora daqui
vamos embora daqui antes que chama a
atenção de pessoas que eu não quero que
esta palavra não parece ser mesmo a
entrada da casa
a porta é maior não é a pessoa que vive
aqui para informar como o caraças com
bananas deixar que a casca e meu pai
melhor carta de vinho e cerveja i e ii
fumo não sei que estou com esta casa mas
não foi nada bom ok temos aqui um papel
o xauth the girl in the door e out meu
deus temos uma criança inaldo único eu
sou eu tenho certeza que o único tu és
tu meu está uma casa de loucos
isto é uma foto em casa qualquer coisa
qualquer coisa boba portas conta que
tiveram que pagar buscas na favela
chapéu mas domingo já te quero mais ter
aqui qualquer coisa dentro desta porta
eu nem vou abrir eu vou me embora
aquela portaria funão abril vou tentar
abrir esta outra vez
pb x salgueiro e ali na porta
alguém matar um cão um homem na porta do
ouviram alguém matar um cão casas já
mataram o cão já mataram cuidado cão não
escolhe se desmanchavam assim já mataram
o cão caraças pagarão nunca lá fora nem
de 1159 xt mentira já passou mais de um
minuto que está a passar aqui a ele já
pegou ela já pagou é que a luz estava
acesa a luz já pegou nenê vai embora de
lá tanto curioso tem de ser um homem
sozinho e vamos lá enfrentar a escuridão
baratas na parede era o que mais faltava
agora baratas os aparelhos a portuguesa
ainda não dá pra abrir o rock que ela
está a piscar está possuída pelo demônio
não vamos passar por ali né não
aqui ninguém eu não devia passar por
aqui eu sei que não via passar por aqui
mas dispensou um jogo dark
vamos lá então voltar aqui outra vez
vamos embora vamos embora na cosmo o
chico não funciona nem isso não consigo
correr na minha própria casa
tanto apagada a luz vermelha é o demônio
está aqui o demônio tac o facto de
mourinho promete o vôo por onde é que eu
vou pra que ela possa agora atravessa
três bancos embora não estão abrigados
no avaí eu vou te passar por exemplo só
assim de green
o que é aquilo é uma mulher é um
uma mulher que não quer passar por lima
eu sou obrigado a passar por lina tem de
ver que alguma coisa pega uma garrafa do
vinho e mandou na cabeça ou o cinema luz
eu tenho com terno ok ok já não é mau eu
não volto demanda interna antónio sá eu
tenho uma mãe tô junto não acredito
junto resultou caraças ok essa porta já
não havia nada aqui ok conseguiu afastar
o demônio encaminha lanterna superpoder
a sandy nonius não a esta proposta não
abra também porque tem que fazer aqui
quadros mais pisar a resto o time é
deixado por questão de frios quentes
passou aqui pois também já tinha música
minha lanterna da outra vez
ok morrer morrerei mudam é isso ai vamos
ficar porque com isto espero que vocês
tenham gostado jogo chama-se yunit vou
deixar o inglês descrição que onetti
punitiva coisas aumentar a descrição
pessoal passa em pilares permitem também
se você já chegaram o site os mesmo 10
não acho que não vale apenas para este
mês ainda não jogaram se primeiro tempo
valeu a pena e é espero que vocês tenham
gostado da chama flec favorito fica em
pé e até a próxima